I'm amazed that they gave me a safety
area and no ink ribbons and I can't
believe it check around the room just in
case I might just because it's hard mode
like every time I've ever been outfit
it's been an hour since we played and I
still can't you know I know
speaking of outfits even though it's the
same day I've changed oh yeah you've
since been pied in the face yeah I lost
a bet like months ago it probably hasn't
been a month it's like been a month ago
the loser was going to get pied in the
face at a random time it happened I got
up alright so now I have changed because
I see you're definitely gonna hit the
nemesis this episode oh [ __ ]
well I know and I told you how that
nemesis worked no I don't know anything
about it and so my fear is and I want to
make this really now I know that but why
won't you understand is that I don't
want to die and redo all the stuff we
just did all from my knowledge I'll do
enough to let you not [ __ ] up well no
actually I won't I can't promise that
yeah I don't I don't believe you like so
I found this room where are we going so
you can't get to that door and left
without the firehose right Thor and
there's this dog central if we go
through the crosshairs this is where I
killed the dogs and then you gotta go
north
I gotta go here all the way north so
there's zoms here there should be the
police station from its memory serves
you go to at the police station again so
I don't know if I qui clarify this in
the first episode this is set before -
this is like they originally called it
resin evil 1.9 in development or 1.5
because it wasn't gonna be a numbered
entry but then they just gave it a three
to keep it consistent I wasn't clear all
right so I'm going here and then I'm
yeah and I'm taking a left and I'm going
Noth mm-hm and I'm avoiding zoms yeah
but watch out for dudes
come on over
oh crap am i taking a left here right
well you could you could search around
in the cars and [ __ ] for I think there's
zombies yeah check like open doors like
that and whatnot but I mean like check
down anyway before you go down there
okay what like down here oh sure
cuz you're not going that way make sure
you're not passing anything up
I don't mean you know what that I'm just
yeah I'm doing a once over here you're
wearing a once over the simple lock that
makes me feel like I could pick it
mm-hmm
try burning it I should
okay there's nothing I'm sorry
there's a book sorry it's kind of you
know going over stuff water is gushing
from a broken hydrant can I collect it
in a bucket
get up get that fire out our CPD Raccoon
City police whoa it's an interesting
shot badly
oh no that guy's super dad
No
stars
oh no I no no no no no no fight with the
monster enter the police I want to
[ __ ] leave yeah good call so [ __ ] you
so you can fight him there for my
remember and Brad had like an ID on him
that gives you weapon parts but you it
shouldn't matter in the long run just
look familiar it is it the same oh no
what am i doing what do I do
I need you to be with me here I just get
that [ __ ] I guess all day who knows we
can come back here yeah really
mmm he's gonna jump he's gonna break in
let him cut off ever I really don't I
would just take those and go where am I
going
oh no you this is the one camera two
you've seen two camera you'd like this I
told you I remember a lot that's the
whole point of the show we
re-established the beginning subside and
play much okay try the party room yeah
the party room is not boarded up go do
their go to there your birthday it's
canceled it's now he said wasn't Leon's
birthday first Dion the Jay
that's right on the ground he's just
this guy like I missed that
[ __ ] Juke I'll kill him and get some
[ __ ] out of ye what am i doing
looks like there's stuff in there yeah
just lead him around
Oh that guy's head on the ground moved
the lockers again ooh
that dudes getting fast how annoying is
that dude he's very annoying
somebody sure yeah he's gonna come in I
might be able to do you think there's
more stuff in here that's my question
you shouldn't be dead yet shitty if this
is before - that's that's correct
oh it doesn't say his daddy's fatally
wounded probably unconscious
there's been reports of a theft in the
Municipal Building no a jewel decorated
clock at the main gate was damaged two
of the 12 gems that are installed in the
face of the clock are missing due to the
lack of available officers at this time
I have no choice but to suspend the
research of this case autopsy one of the
missing gems this is about gems okay so
I'm gonna try to do a quick about-face
here here we go
it didn't work Oh got it
is that Mary Kishore allen iverson Oh
without a doubt I'm just not sure cuz
like it's welcome Leon [ __ ] Police
Department has party hats for a new
recruit when we have new people like
James Bobby Hayes no I'm just kidding
oh yeah that's what we need
cuz his head dudes fast yeah sorry Co
storage doing no Herridge this is the
his Marvin's office but where door
marked storage that oh crap I think
there's a zombie somewhere hilarious I
got it dammit I don't got it I didn't
get it so when you chose to run to the
police station instead of fight that em
assist you see that little animation she
did talking in here no no no that's
where you came from
yes it is do you want a bet before this
door opens $100 $100 $100 front door
dammit you played resin evil - I did it
this is the same I didn't take the bet
though doesn't count stay on your left
your left yes it might be never mind you
gotta go go right and then the doors
back behind where he is near that like
power generator thing
it's the door you enter this room in and
ready to try that's why that's why I
made a mistake I'm sure okay yeah I've
got a team I'm running out of space I
mean check the rest of room so you just
take it check those drawers too in case
and watch out for this is dude behind
these doors
you'd hear him he'd be like dead what
was that the nemesis oh I don't know the
number to this you think we could cheat
and look it out but I don't think that's
genuine you're right it wasn't in that
document I read right no I don't know I
think it would have been a nom
okay
I think I got a killer you got a joker
nope uh yeah you could if you leader
didn't you oh oh go there oh I went
upstairs I made a call it's just like a
green herb or something sorry
letting go oh my god it's been so long
since I've saved know it has mmm it
really has just use a green herb they
can come downstairs now I know I'm
considering my options free up space to
your fun okay so do you think I should
go upstairs or back downstairs
that's Caesars and I would also like you
could probably shotgun I'm on these two
dates we using one shell on their heads
okay I don't know if the stairs gonna
affect their heads that evening I went
really well
well you're you started at you - yeah
that right there dead girl nice
oh no that's one I see him okay yeah so
I don't know we ever talked about this
Andres able to that door does nothing
like you can't unlock it there's nothing
behind it oh yeah this is where you did
the jewels do I do stuff with the jewels
in this one go up and look at the
statute
No
I could put the jewel in his hand
the Stars headquarters no what was that
the nemesis is it you remember you lied
to me last episode do you understand how
far back it will take us if I die [ __ ]
try the the room under those stairs I
mean there's a lot of dudes there's no
room under these stairs it's there's the
guy you up to this floor oh right yeah
used to be a savory one - I'm trying
number what it isn't this if it is a
same room why had to go back through all
this [ __ ] hmm am I supposed to be
killing these dudes like one way to do
it I there's a best way yeah he's
[ __ ] huge
that was a surprise killing something
important can you just use the blue gem
on that statue I don't know should I
check it oh good yeah there's that fat
guy
well I don't think that's probably in
front of it it's like the camera
confuses me okay great all right I was
worth a try
was it I used to have a friend called
worth I where is he
show me I used to be a fat guy right
here okay great
just let him yeah into here and then cat
mouse around the statue be good honey
speeds up and that's funny uh-huh yeah
the fact I might not be around yet go
thanks some serious Jukes so so they're
gonna be at the bottom of stairs wait
what
that didn't happen before okay wait wait
wait before you move you got a few
seconds to plan it out shaaka yeah
probably I don't know what else I'm
gonna do I see that I'm taking a hit
yeah
good shotgun I try to go for the head
shot I've said okay
on both of them yet great oh wait come
here no nice Heat good could digest dude
theoretically if you wanted to if you
don't to waste in their shell it depends
on if the camera angle changes I can't
see very well
yeah Liam I think there are two guys
there I got you
I definitely think there are two crap
you died this dude for sheer crap I
[ __ ] it
I [ __ ] it oh yeah geez I'm actually
really glad I've had the first two under
my belt because I feel much more
comfortable juking like my Juke skills
are at all-time high
all-time high you be there and grab
isn't here nice because it
it's a pen I think we should I know
they're limited but if I if I die I'm
losing so much so much progress okay I
need to go to the box
garrison these ribs like I'm you
understand my fear here like well we
have 40 I would say we have 40 minutes
of progress that could be lost if I
don't save that's my fear and I think
it's a very legitimate fear
give me more gunpowder give me
everything are they just we're using the
same place a lot of it yeah is that kind
of like lazy again it wasn't supposed to
be a numbered title until like into
development I
I vote save what do you think I mean you
have five ribbons now so you have some
some leeway you could save
I also think I should be making some
stuff yeah yeah I'd like to make some
Shogun shells um
don't I have more red they never give
you enough red plants you know that
they're powerful all right so what am I
making I'm gonna make some eyes well
make them before I save I got a and B if
I combine them I can make C but I think
I'd rather have shotgun shells yeah I
guess so
personally thoughts yeah if you're
accurate with them that makes sense I'd
also think I should be making bullets I
just did 101 DNA okay so I'm making two
rounds of bullets yeah okay I think
we've made good decisions yeah me too
should I keep
all these shells of me I can combine
these yeah alright we're good
God organization is actually pretty hot
like it makes me feel great to like
organize my stuff I'm not gonna yeah
yeah no it makes me excited like it's
not just cool it's like I get a thrill
from it it it's a bit weird well you
play resmio for that's when you'd start
to like have some [ __ ] rotate stuff
and fit them in the attached box I think
that's where it comes from like I get
excited about that kind of stuff like
it's a cool minigame that gives me a a
rush is the right word for it
mm-hmm a rush what this is a giant safe
room
yeah I think the typewriter is still by
the front desk you just didn't have
anchor pins on you just didn't matter I
am obviously not sure where to go I got
a gem did I save yeah I saved
so it's like now what there anything
else in here you didn't get also should
i what did I do with that gym I put it
in that say box should I take it with me
yeah probably if you alright you could
probably get rid of shotgun shells the
extra ones what do you wear the ink
ribbons with this thing examine it maybe
oh yeah that's a good call I should know
that I should go check I should know
better a sapphire shining in blue as
opposed to a ruby shining in blue it
rubies are red that's my point why did
that
nevermind
my crew bees are red violets are blue
[ __ ] you Mary no I'm just curious where
you think I should go now because I feel
like no I've I've actually seen all the
open areas I mean the only thing I can
think of wait no there's a door we're
just all getting walk through there
the one on the bottom no like next to
the save room go back down look at
there's one like Napoli came through
there's another yellow door there you
see it oh maybe that's something no
memory okay so I leave the safe room
that's a dude to tangle with and I go
left and then I go past the room I came
in no you don't go past the room he came
in is that one oh it's this one yeah so
I'm going to the first door whatever
that is yeah okay
[ __ ] it [ __ ] yeah you know come on
Benson [ __ ] probably deej him up nice
sorry there's another one I think she's
in this hallway no oh wait oh yeah it is
this right there I forgot it was right
there I was trying to pass her like it
just [ __ ] down kill her thanks I'm
[ __ ] up you me I saved right it's
where I get anxiety I think you did I
did if he didn't the viewers right now
are gonna be freaking out be like I
can't she finds out if she didn't save I
remember doing it
[Music]
then nope okay load game you have no
memory when in doubt always follow your
nose I have no memory of this
I can't stop won't stop so I might have
to put some stuff away that's all you
lost so much progress everything is fine
okay that's what we've decided grant
where if that's a blue gem that's like
he to progression or more like the
Resident Evil the tiger eyes in the
remaster right I have no idea so we're
at the same page just duped big dumb
dumb dumb dumb
okay very skinny that's the briefing
room I don't know if you remember this
hallway I don't I forget a lot about
this honestly oh yeah
dick [ __ ] him up well remember to reload
manually F in like three more shots I
might get in trouble for this oh I don't
have all my shells that's alright
you don't need shells just you should
find I think there's a hell on the next
room in that briefing room yep
oh you got so lucky he went around you
yes
ah just to kill I'm just a girl killing
zombies so whiny waiter
oh nice Jill ID there's Cod there was a
wasn't there a thing earlier that said I
needed that I can't remember him
it's so much easier when you know how to
play a game this is like this is a
Starsky same goddamn room like they
didn't I wait go to the back own sorry
[Music]
180 no oh you should have practice 118 I
should actually you know what I also
haven't done what I haven't like
defendant usen't used those defense
moves yeah like I know what I'm saying I
don't know how to do it I take this I
want I'm sure sure you don't know
a biological accident that was okay back
room maybe blue jam it up I don't know
see it's just like a machine that's like
insert blue gem here for Sun Chips
that's what I ate today I remember this
room I have oh I don't have a lighter
[Music]
you're right near the same room
there's no sweet well they cleared that
up
so nothing uh-oh check the scope the
Stars card because I don't know if
that's gonna open that door or not sure
an ID card four stars with Jill's
picture on it that did not help just
that woman with her little butt hanging
out my image oh is that my nemesis I
actually don't know what what to do eat
now obvious the Stars card is the thing
you need first some something
yeah chiming try it on that door I guess
I would I don't know if that makes sense
probably go back to the save room
regardless oh wait no keep going to the
end of this hallway did you yet I mean
at least check out what's down there's
no door it's probably boarded up but
the windows are coming up already
boarded up hmm Reds
oh no I'm full you can get him after no
I want these those are really good Reds
are super important
all right so save room yeah which is oh
it might even be worth getting those
Reds I agree I think I should more save
room try to start you stupid [ __ ] I
would be angry too
oh crap I just still feel like we don't
have a direction got the card find it
what do I do with it and what do I do
with this gem put the ink ribbons
shotgun shells I would say it's worth
getting the red herbs might not be
exciting but I would do it I'll tell a
funny story while you go did I not make
that scroll bar it shows you what think
oh I guess I didn't make more ammo
hey did I didn't cuz look I have one
ammo - Amma I would bring those hanging
on your rounds with you oh yeah you got
a few gunpowder A's right I could take
one how many right herbs were there two
or three - okay let's go get them you
ready mm-hmm
get him girl [ __ ] you [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] you have to go by on the way the
Stars room just kill them perv out it
was really hard to determine when I
should kill people because I hate them
wonder of the Nemesis system works like
is it based off of time or is it based
off of progression certain areas will
the Nemesis always come find me when I
reach a certain point or if I spend too
long doing something will he find me you
know I think it's I don't know I think
it's certain areas based on what we
think I'm curious how he works
do you know what I'm supposed to be
doing now because after I do this yeah
go to Stars got a plan use your card I
don't where is this check your map after
you Jesus oh you got to go past or the
other way well I mean put those in the
say box first and they check your map
when you're in here cuz should I come I
should combine these right no I was
saving for now oh just don't combine I
feel like you should always combine Reds
they're so hot well yeah they don't do
much if you know what I'm saying like
yeah you could remind one of them I
don't know like in the off chance that
you want to combine a green to blue
later you might be wasting green with a
red got it okay I'll just leave him then
uh is this everything I need I don't
know if you need the blue gem but you
might a you in case okay
checking map yeah Syria
where am I going
his safe room still red
it's not green until I leave it you
check those shelves next to you check
this back room right
I checked these I don't know if I
checked it asking everything oh there's
appears to be a note right here pretty
obvious now that you mention it my
sanity is at its end I still can't
believe this is happening
we lost another man yesterday mayor one
of our better marksman one day away from
retirement he saw me panic once we were
overrun by the zombies but he never came
back to save me make that up it doesn't
say that that's why it says it when the
time came to return the debt I ran I
still can hear him calling out my name I
can hear the screams coming from behind
the sounds is flesh being stripped from
his bones I was afraid I just came out
to see him the 27th it's a cold day and
I don't feel great I have a bit of a flu
stomach's in knots the fight to stay
alive continues I took out several
zombies who managed to break through the
barricades now I'm cutting through the
chill with whisky unloading my Mossberg
on anything undead it made me think of
my tiny puppy Fred who was been it's
such comfort to me in these later years
that shotgun became a close friend of
mine just like Fred I've lasted many a
zombie into fertilizer with it we've
lost 13 men of yesterday and three hours
we'll bicker over trivial things in the
meeting room like why is the sky blue
because the reflection of the ocean or
does it like actually have that color
naturally it's a total waste of time
when I finish this bottle my old friend
Mossberg will be turning one last body
into fertilizer
peace at last that's a really good
backstory I felt really honest yeah I
feel bad for Fred yeah he's probably
find a better family where am I going
I passed the the lady zombie Oh to the
second door
got it yeah when he came through oh I
can totally Juke this I got this
[Music]
you might have to kill her like shotgun
so he doesn't catch up to you or his
[ __ ] Joker he just didn't do it on
the back [ __ ] [ __ ] up yeah just go
she touched me Deena I like
I'm [ __ ] injured we met like one of
these right know that stars the door oh
we're looking for numbers no I think
that's from the damn I can't believe I'm
in caution that really sucks it's like a
hundred percent my fault oh my god oh
wait no you go the wrong way open this
open what he's a map sorry
oh you're supposed to go upstairs okay
so getting hit by that lady was
unnecessary that's correct
mm I'm glad that we've yeah oh my god
I'm about to [ __ ] get hit again
I don't know how knowing that I know no
he's dead he's dead
a bee
mad about this lady I don't like her and
want to kill her kind of healing do you
have on you I have one red and blue drug
which I'm gonna have to take the next
time I [ __ ] get hit [ __ ] you only one
of us can wear a miniskirt just deed top
deed alright
yeah I feel like we learned that lesson
in the last one and the lesson was it's
not worth getting injured it's just like
it's more worth the mo you know what I
mean
shit's fátima fat fat big badge he was
mean me this place is cleaner it so this
is this start this requires a key hmm
was her ID for I don't know I'm just
gonna go back to the lobby or something
I don't think of anything this way hmm
I guess you got to go back to the lobby
this is a lot harder when you don't know
what you're doing no you took me the
wrong way all right where are you fatty
where is he there is we're okay we're
okay we're not great but we're okay
we'll figure it out where am i gone
second door
yeah the far door she's dead now though
so you're good [ __ ] be dead I hate that
lady
totally worth every bullet speaking of
which I think I'm gonna be I'm running
out of bullets okay so I'm going out the
storm yeah feel like my nemesis got to
be
it helps huh dude this affects all of us
I'm going back through here mm-hmm
I should check this room out yeah maybe
there's something we missed in like a
computer
oh that's hand Grand Rounds oh you you
just gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme good
30 on that's the greatest gift no no
save ribbons it's some [ __ ] though I
will you know what I think I will
there you go okay so we had to come back
here anyway I just led you in the right
direction twice so now you probably get
a number which you did a key that seems
fair evidence room so this will give you
a number okay
4 4 3 1 2 2 3 1 4 I'm just kidding is 4
3 1 2 1 1 3 oh my god 4 1 2 . it's 4 2 3
1
no you remember it 4 3 1 2 no that's the
first one I said you're dumb no it's not
you're dumb and your mistake is assuming
everyone's as dumb as you are you go
that way oh I'm dumb because you're dumb
just go I will
so back to the lockers other side the
other this is gonna give me like
hopefully a key because if it gives me a
gem I don't know what the [ __ ] to do
with it all right four one three two
3 3 3 3 3 it's 3 4 3 1 2 I was kidding
3 you did this one - for notes - it's
for how do you feel
sucks alright start on it that's is that
the Starsky yes or is it the emblem key
nice that's misleading no can I be heard
you have to check them to identify it'll
say stars gives you check it yeah you're
right there's a star on it right there
you're smart
special tactics and Rescue Squad now
let's go to that thing that I risked my
life for twice read caution go upstairs
sorry about that
places confusing
you
light of my life
all right couple jokes
just this dum-dum and a chubby dum-dum
got it
that wasn't very yeah there was
something about the first game where ki
was so valuable here I feel like they're
like more means to an end
it's like less like opening a door yeah
feel like you're making him like that
simple door if you want back in the
alleyway I think there was a few action
I was making fun of you to clarify
Chris's desk Oh
disorganized [ __ ]
give me the oh yes I will
what I just hate when your inventory
fills up each other there's a health
care sometimes it if you're Claire into
it doesn't have your dumb
I didn't need that gem don't if you
start blaming I'm like a help I'm
blaming you because of my is that noise
I blame you because I have depended on
you for so long there's berries dusters
hand got him on it yes
hot [ __ ] another 30 oh look it again the
Jose there was two unless that was all
because yeah that's great this has been
the best all right so we're good
I think that's Jimmy look some more I
got I got to come back here anyway cuz I
need that spray when you're on hard mode
you really can't [ __ ] around with stuff
like this you know so I'm probably gonna
I know it
[Music]
[Applause]
yes you can clearly you can here's my
suggestion
you go back to safe room deposit some
stuff come back get that first day spray
go back to safe from saving first two
episodes and now you know you the
lockpick you're going to the alux
episode right past that fire right I'm
gonna the fire hose eventually you can
put out both fires god damn that's why
you're here they don't call me like the
party planner for nothing they say don't
nobody calls you that you said they
don't call me Mikey party yeah well
can't make an omelet without shooting a
few zombie
oh no okay yeah yeah I don't know about
the first day anymore Mary he's got a
[ __ ] rocket launcher I'm gonna say
firm you can't touch me
have we talked about this what safe room
is not safe anymore how what what what's
happening yeah get rid of that blue jam
think you need them but who knows I
almost want to save I'm a freezing
[ __ ] kill me
you could then he used it the first day
of spring next if you could dodge them
successfully I say just go for the first
days spray might be worth the risk
I don't think I can if you dodge him you
definitely have to leave the police
station
should I he'll take the lock like with
you in case you can't get back to safety
I think I should save use a greener I
don't feel good about that let's think
about this use a green herb your full
health
you could go try for the first-aid spray
dodge him go get guest
hold on listen Brad I get use a green
herb get full health and then like you
dodged him best-case scenario you dodged
him get the first day spray come back
dodge him and then you leave with the
first-aid spray in your pack worst case
you go up you get hit you still get the
first taste break come back no my worst
case is that I die and I lose like 30
minutes of progress you could save now
if you want to and then next time try to
get the first day square if you [ __ ]
up just wipe and let him kill you what
how quickly does he kill you
he's fast I mean like he's hurt you a
lot will he follow me up the stairs
stairs I think he would come up there
eventually
I'm Ennis alright I've made a call I'm
gonna save and then I'm gonna do it for
funsies this episode I'm gonna have to
do it again next episode yeah but if you
succeed that's not it's okay oh you're
saving anyway I'm gonna save and we're
gonna call it but I'm gonna really have
that much progress though because we
were figuring things out but I'm not
willing to die alright fine fine fine or
I am like you can talk me into it should
I go for it should I go for it I'll go
for it yeah but I'm saying I'm gonna
lose a half a lot about this yeah who
cares but you did it wasn't really half
it was a half hour it's a half hour of
my life and I want it oh it wasn't it
wasn't cuz last time you said you could
just immediately dart to the lobby I
realize we spent half an hour I don't
wanna argue with you about this
you spoke we spent half an hour trying
to figure out to go back to the lobby
you could do that in three minutes try
it be brave
make give the people what they want hmm
do it
what about one way away it brings
something else to heal with though I
have a full thing you'd be fun I don't
know if the first day spray is that
important I have these I just don't
you're not coming back here what do you
want from me try to go for the first day
spray where I'm in the Stars room so I'm
going up the stairs okay here's my thing
bring
if you want to I don't know how bad you
want that first dates where do you think
you need it it's not worth losing Ivan
they don't tell us over it I'll do it
would you rather save here or try to get
past him and get that out of the way and
then save in the lobby bring ink ribbons
if that's what you want to do there's a
typewriter in the lobby
you're confusing man okay okay there's
no just save here no you've convinced me
of otherwise what are you gonna do go
back to the lobby I'm gonna go for the
first aids tray in the middle
the first a series probably not worth it
now that I think of it yeah do it you
can toss him it's a tight it's a tight
squeeze if you can master that dodge
press r1 r2 you're okay no here is that
the same time here's what I think will
be more worthwhile when you're fighting
it go upstairs and let's [ __ ] run
like hell all right this is your fault
you [ __ ] told me to do this it's not
sing sorry what a maroon he's telling
you go to the [ __ ] stars room I don't
think that's it that's what he said I
don't think that's what he said
wait that's not where are these guys
where are they you knew Tony who's gonna
follow me I don't want I did say that
you could come be I said he follows you
throughout the game
I'd go hurry where to the stars hmm the
stars room don't yell at me know it that
one go there there's a red herb here if
you want to try to go to that dead-end
and get it every way is there no I got
them both
get Thursday's right it'll be worth it
you're just gonna have to do some
dodging so I don't fight with you got
very upset yeah do it
alright so yeah that's good yes yes if
you get to the bottom of stairs and you
still have not gotten hit
[ __ ] that savoury I'm going to lobby
today yeah you might have to figure out
the the dodge the r1 r2 dice back you're
good you got it I don't got it going
down the stairs and then am I going to
the second room the one in the far end
of the hallway yes
fire fire yes I don't feel good about
this he's really fast
the only reason could hit last time okay
okay okay hear me out hear me out
you're good you know what you're doing
go has left go left and then up okay
okay okay listen me out you hear me out
you just got a first date I want to go
right no I know I meant
hog that left side wall and then go up
hear me out okay you're not in the best
situation like the worst case scenario
if it hits you and you end up using the
first-day spray this whole thing is very
bad about it you're fine just do it
go just go oh I think he just fired at
you okay um should I he'll let me see
your health oh there's a [ __ ] zombie
don't I'd if you get [ __ ] about if
you think about the ax toss then he'll
yeah just heal heal heal heal heal heal
heal him ah yeah the red
it's fine just get there okay hear me
out
you're literally back to square one it
was just it was funny for me that's the
silver lining just heal and you're back
- there you go just get for the stairs
keys
I did that on accident it's not funny
far door far far far
you're good you're gonna go okay [ __ ] I
hope you have to dodge guys in here shut
up sorry I'm very upset yes I hope so
this game gets more tense as you go no
[ __ ] no wait I'm going in here please
just go [ __ ] save this place oh [ __ ]
you want to sit yeah you want to say yes
but he's gonna okay
you literally it doesn't it but you're
back to like net health it doesn't you
didn't lose or gain anything I am upset
but you you got the first-aid sprit
helped you way back and now you're like
why what do you mean well let me pick
anything you press the right button yeah
circle no it's X
maybe yo you can't save when he's
chasing you maybe or overwrite the
warehouse that works too why can't you I
don't know
Oh hard mode can you like two saves yeah
you picked our mode all right sweet we
saved that's it let him come in and kill
you no I don't think he comes in I don't
think it comes in this room oh this is
way more fun when I don't actually like
remember a lot of words this is so much
more fun for me for me at least oh my
god there's other stuff in this room I
think that's that's it for resident evil
3 nemesis oh the penultimate how far am
I like a seventh of the way we do well
you're doing okay guess it this one's
fun I'll see you guys on the next
episode
yeah I was exhausting I